Okay, welcome to Real Time
on CNN.
We're here
with Democratic strategist,
and co-host of
the Politics War Room podcast,
James Carville.
And host of The Rubin Report
on YouTube
and Rumble, Dave Rubin.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
Okay, here are the questions.
For Dave,
"What did you think
of Elon Musk's trip to Israel?
Do you think he
no longer harbors antisemitic
and conspiratorial beliefs?"
Oh, well,
he never had antisemitic
or conspiratorial beliefs
in the first place.
-But Elon Musk...
-BILL MAHER: Well.
...is not an antisemite.
There are plenty of antisemites
out there.
You called a whole bunch
of them out during the show.
I mean, Elon Musk going
to Israel was absolutely great.
I think too many people now
don't believe anything they see.
-But they do believe Elon Musk.
-BILL: Well--
So him going there and saying,
"I saw the 47 minutes
of footage."
He's wearing dog tags of--
You know,
from one of the families...
-Okay. Well, I mean, it could--
-...who lost their kids.
There's a lot
of antisemites out there,
but Elon Musk
is not one of them.
-Okay, that may be true. I...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
I mean-- I mean... (CHUCKLES)
...look, he's a hard guy
to follow all the time.
-I've tried, and the one--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
This thing did test my patience
with him,
because he may not be
an antisemite,
but when someone tweets
what they tweeted...
-DAVE RUBIN: Right.
-...and he tweets,
"You have spoken
the actual truth."
It looks really antisemitic.
-So-- I mean, come on.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
DAVE: I mean, I don't know--
I don't know how in the weeds
you wanna get on the comment.
But the comment was really--
BILL: We do.
What is the comment?
The comment
that he was responding to
was about
that there are left-wing,
thought of
as "Jewish organizations,"
like the ADL,
that are aiming their fire
the wrong way all the time.
So they're attacking him, right?
As opposed to attacking
the people that they--
-That are actually antisemites.
-BILL: No, I think--
Like the lefties that you
were talking about earlier.
All right, my understanding
of it was that he was supporting
the idea that--
Well, you heard
when you mentioned it during--
You're exactly right.
It was the greatest act
of Jew-washing I've ever seen.
-(LAUGHS)
-After he said something
like that.
(CHUCKLES, SPEAKS INDISTINCTLY)
Yeah, I've never heard
that term.
Well, I mean, it's what--
-it's what you do
when you screw up...
-BILL: Yeah. Oh, I get it.
...and you go, "All right,
all right. I'll say a thing"
I mean, come on.
Look, I have no-- no idea.
The last thing I wanna do
is pick a fight with a guy
worth a trillion dollars.
But that dude is weird, man.
I'm gonna tell you.
There's something weird
about that boy.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-BILL: Uh...
Uh, James, you famously said,
"It's the economy, stupid,
but voters seem to be responding
to positive economic news...
voters don't seem
to be responding
to positive economic news
in the polls.
How do you explain this?"
Well, you know,
you got 60 percent
of the Republicans
that believe the Earth
is 6,000 years old.
BILL: Oh,
that's not a good answer.
-But, if what--
-BILL: Come on.
I'm just thinking,
you say the polls, all right?
You-- Look,
we had 5.6 percent growth.
All right? I-- By any record--
Now, if people don't feel it,
and I-- Look, I think
we should've made a change.
I-- I-- You and I agree on that.
And I don't know
how much of it is
is that they can't see
beyond the present.
I mean, the cost of living
has hurt people.
But you just can't look
at this economy
and go out and say,
"This is a bad economy."
(HESITATES) That's impossible.
But that's not really what
you wanna tell the voters.
You can't run--
But I'm not running
for office, Bill.
I'm answering a question
on a television show.
-If I wasn't--
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
Okay, but you're-- but you're--
The reason why you're on
a television show
is because you're
a known strategist.
So we're asking
for your strategy,
and your strategy seems
to be to tell the voters,
"You don't know
what you're talking about."
And I don't think
that's a good way
to get elected,
and I'm not a strategist.
I would not say that.
-But you can't--
-You just said it to me.
-(GUESTS CHUCKLE)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
DAVE: He's not running
for office.
-I mean, look at the sweatshirt.
-I know, but people...
Here's what I think it is.
People--
The things that--
Like you can cite
the statistics.
And yes,
inflation is going down.
It's going
in the right direction.
But the things that--
The things people buy every day
in this country.
-Bullets, eggs--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-BILL: Gas.
-Ga-- Gas is down.
-Ga-- Not here.
-But, I--
Well, I'm just telling you,
the price of gas...
-BILL: Yes. Right.
-We produce more--
We pump more oil
than we ever have in history.
Anywhere. We pump more oil
than Saudi Arabia.
All right?
Just so you know that.
But if you ask people,
you know, "Do you think
that the Democrats
and Biden has been--"
You know, "Oh, yeah,
of course he is, 100 percent."
(HESITATES) I can't--
The fact that people
believe something
doesn't make it a fact.
There's a big story in
The Wall Street Journal today.
The crime rate
has dropped significantly.
Try to tell--
(HESITATES) Argue with someone.
But the crimes per 100,000,
I think, were 738,
and are down to 362
or something like that.
You-- I gotta sit here and act
like I'm a factual klutz
because somebody
believes something
that's not true?
I don't buy that.
Okay. Well, then we'll move on.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-BILL: Um...
-(CHUCKLES)
Mike...
-(LAUGHS)
-(BILL CHUCKLING)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
So, uh, Mike Johnson,
he's from your home state
of Louisiana.
-Oh, man.
-BILL: The Speaker of the House.
I read today,
he wrote a foreword in a book
that conscribes
to conspiracy theories
and homophobic insults.
I thought, "Mike Johnson wrote
the foreword to the Bible?"
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Uh...
Do you think Mike Johnson
can hold his party together,
now that he
has taken the mantle?
First of all,
I don't think
he can hold his party together.
Second of, you're exactly right,
Mike Johnson
and what he believes
is one of the greatest threats
we have today
to the United States.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-But I promise you.
I know these people.
BILL: You're talking
about Christian nationalism.
-JAMES CARVILLE: Absolutely.
-I was talking about it
at the end...
This is a bigger threat
than Al-Qaeda
to this country.
They--
And let me tell you something.
They have
the Speaker of the House,
they got probably--
At least
two Supreme Court justices,
maybe more, all right?
Don't kid yourself.
And people in the press
have no idea
who this guy is,
how he was formed,
what the threat is,
and this is a fundamental threat
to the United States.
It is a fundamental--
They don't believe
in the Constitution,
they'll tell you that.
Mike Johnson himself says,
"What is democracy,
but two wolves
and a lamb having lunch?"
And that's what they really,
really, really believe.
And to say, "Oh, come on, man.
That's just some crazy shit."
No, no.
They-- They believe that.
And they're coming,
and they've
been doing it forever.
They're funded. They're funded.
-They're relentless.
-BILL: Yeah.
And, you know,
they probably won't win
for a while, but they might.
And if they do, it's--
You blow-- The whole country
blows a gasket.
You just have to look
at that painting.
I think it's a Kinkade painting,
that a lot of them like,
where Jesus
is handing the Constitution
-to Thomas Jefferson.
-JAMES: Sure.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-BILL: I mean,
if you can look at that and go,
"Mm. That's the way
it probably happened."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-I know it-- I know it well.
-That wasn't a photo?
-BILL: No, no.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-BILL: Um.
"Is the rise of anti-immigration
Dutch politician
Geert Wilders--"
Ah, I remember interviewing him
for Religulous...
-Yeah. Yeah.
-...way back in 2007.
"A warning to the liberals
in America
that they need to take
our immigration crisis
more seriously?"
So, if you don't follow
the story,
Geert Wilders,
he's been running forever
in Holland.
Uh. You know,
of course, The New York Times
calls him a far rightist.
They call all these people,
I mean, Meloni
in Italy is another one.
Um, Viktor Orbán
is kind of a far rightist
in Hungary, um, but not--
I think some of them are just...
Brexit in England
was part of this.
People are feeling
they are not, uh,
welcome, almost,
in their own home
because of the kind of, uh,
immigration that these people
are fighting against, so--
But most of these people
are not far right
by any way that we would think
of far right in that they--
Like that they're racist.
I actually met with Orbán
in Budapest
and I talked to him
for a little while,
and all he kept saying was,
"You know, I love Hungary.
That's all. I love my people.
I love my country."
That's it. I don't know
what accent that was,
-but that basically...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
That's a dead-on impression
of him, exact... (HESITATES)
-Can you do his walk?
-DAVE: (CHUCKLES) He kind of--
There's a little bit
of a waddle.
But all of these guys,
Geert Wilders,
he wants Holland
to be for the Dutch, right?
-Like, that's what he wants.
-BILL: That's racist.
That's racist. That's what
they would tell you, right?
No, no. Wait, you meant
that literally or sarcastically?
No, no, no. I'm just-- No.
I don't know what
we're talking about.
-But, um...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I was just gonna say,
Dutch for the Dutch.
I would amend that if it was me.
Dutch values.
DAVE: No, Dutch values,
of course.
You don't have
to be actually Dutch.
You don't have to be White.
That's what I think
is great about America.
-It's the idea.
-DAVE: Of course.
As long as you subscribe
to our ideas,
which again, to your point,
and what I was saying
at the end of the show,
that we're not
a Christian nation.
That's not what it is.
As a country where
we have the First Amendment,
then everybody
should be welcome.
No, of course,
it's not about skin color,
but it is about culture.
-So, what happens is,
all of these people...
-BILL: Culture matters.
...whether they're in France
or Belgium
or any of the countries
that you just mentioned,
they're realizing,
"Wow, we've got
literally millions of people
in our borders
that are chanting for genocide,
and gas the Jews,
and the rest of it."
And by the way,
it doesn't stop
with the Jews, right?
I mean, they were
at the Christmas tree
in Times Square yesterday
or two days ago.
So, people are realizing that,
and they're looking for anybody,
and for some reason they always
come with crazy hair,
that will-- that will fix some
of this stuff.
(HESITATES)
I kind of have trouble--
I think your question was,
does the election
in the Netherlands...
-Is that some part of a warning?
-BILL: A harbinger for--
Do you want
a short, truthful answer or--
-BILL: Yes.
-Yes, it does.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-JAMES: Okay? It does.
Said-- Because people--
But understand this.
-People like immigrants, okay?
-DAVE: Right.
What they don't like
is disorder.
And when you become
the disorder party,
whatever it is, you pay a price.
Now, one of the reasons
that we're having this problem,
this is what 3.6 percent
unemployment does for you.
You think we're the only people
that know that?
Or you think--
And by the way, somebody--
If you got a woman
that lives in Honduras,
and she walks
with a ten-year-old
and a six-year-old
to the Mexican border,
and wants to come
in this country,
"Come on in, lady.
You motivated person."
-We need you.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-Period.
-DAVE: No. No.
You can't come.
We have a border.
We have a country.
You either have a country
or you don't.
-I mean--
-Every border had refugees.
Every border has asylum.
Yeah, but you can't
just let them walk in.
-I'm sorry.
-That's what the issue is.
I'm for a six--
Somebody walks
with two kids 600 miles
to come in this country,
-"I got a job for you, lady.
Come see me."
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-BILL: All right--
-Find me one roofer in Florida
that was born
in the United States.
-BILL: I got a job too.
-Just find one.
I got a job and that means
getting out on time.
Thank you, CNN.
We'll see you next week.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Thank you, everybody.